[Music]
he don't know exactly just what i became
well you sound just like
billy joe armstrong that's amazing life
could be a dream sweetheart
it wasn't long ago that i was just like
you
now i think i'm sick and i want to go um
justin just listened to the entire album
of dookie
on his drive isn't that that's an
embarrassing
title to say dookie that is my first cd
that i ever owned
ah donkey by green day it's the best you
know i was just thinking about it that
you remember like what big hits um bask
it was basket case then whoever come
around they were like those were the two
you hate my voice christians
i don't love it but i also your face
when you're singing is so crazy so is
billy joe's
it's
i can't believe you just compared
yourself do
your eyebrows point down
and it looks like your eyes are bleeding
when you're singing that
anyway this is a very special quarantine
issue of life is sure issue
what did i say issue weird messed it up
you don't both have to occasionally mess
up the beginning of your podcast life
um
yes it is very special um maybe the most
special one really i think so i can't
wait then we'll wait we'll see what
happens okay so far so far i think it's
so far it's off to a hell of a start uh
yeah you have that yeah
uh anyway yeah
but uh it was basket case and when i
come around i can feel the coffee
coursing through my veins no it was
those two were hits and but back then we
had cassette tapes
and we would play the whole it was hard
to like skip you know you couldn't skip
to another song i'm glad i had the cd
yeah but but my point is it we would
just let it play and all of the songs
were so good they were so like
catchy and infectious the whole album is
so good do you know who we should have
on the show at some point uh
yeah i think all of them all three of
them kind of three
one two three sean connery
i don't send sean hayes
um billy joe armstrong yeah
yeah
uh and we can tell the story about how
he once gave me a tattoo do you know
who'd be excited if we had him on your
girlfriend maggie she would be over the
moon yeah she loves uh who else does she
love i mean she loves music in general
but that type that yeah
which makes it very strange that she's
interested in me at all
it does you seem so
out of
her uh
no no to
taste but like i know well i think she's
evolved wow whoa do you
i can't wait or devolve yeah yeah uh
billy joe is cool i i had a really wild
night with him no when no not what well
let's we'll save it
okay um yeah he's funny what a tease i
know well uh why were we talking about
green day uh i just listened to okay
because you just listened to the album
yeah it's as simple as that and hey it's
a quarantine episode we could do
whatever we want that's right no rules
we don't have to lose wow we're so punk
yeah so punk rock yeah oh man what a
great album
i don't think we're allowed to play this
nope okay
um nice try though
something's on my mind it's been for
quite some time
it's time
[Laughter]
all right um we're gonna uh talk we're
gonna end this
disgusting and that's been the best the
uh quoting episode hope you guys have a
great week i told you it was special and
we'll see you on tuesday okay
it's special because it was our quickest
um okay we're gonna call our friend dr
kessler catch up with him with check-in
yeah we're gonna on the state pivot
really quickly the medical state of the
country yeah um
and
this is going to be a tough transition
to make but let's just go ahead and do
it from dookie to dr dave uh-huh
you know dr dave probably makes the
occasional dookie we all do yeah
i bet they're very healthy too
hello uh dr dave kessler please hey
um speaking dave hello
it's justin long of life is short um hey
dave what are your i'm gonna throw a
curveball at you right away
just knock you off your your post what
are your impressions or your memories of
the album dookie by green day
i told you i
don't yeah that's a curveball don't have
many memories of that album okay
uh second question
now that you're thrown a little bit and
trying to get your bearings straight
uh how are wearing straight yeah yeah
pretty good though um how's it going
pretty good
um are you at the hospital now dave
no i'm home i was i actually just
took a nap oh nah
woke up oh sorry yeah i'm sorry
which makes the last question i asked
even more annoying
oh god
um
dave we have we have two questions for
you that we were um hoping you could
help us with uh the first one is we we
heard as did i think everyone the
exciting news about moderna i don't
think we've talked about this yet the
pharmaceutical company moderna that uh
sounds like the first phase of their
their trials for the vaccine went much
better than expected do you
do you have any
any information and if it's bad news
maybe don't share it
there's nothing really to totally weigh
in it's too early yeah i mean it's good
it's good that it's not bad news but
this sort of like
people jumping the gun on the scientific
process a little bit to overclock
because how long uh is that process i
mean they said it's phase one i think
they're they mentioned phase
three going into effect in july i mean i
feel like i've seen some quotes from
past vaccine trials right being like the
fastest or around 18 months to two years
or so really
after the vaccines are out really in
like big numbers too is when you start
to see you know some of that final data
on on safety
um but but it's it's good news you know
i mean we'll take it one step at a time
i'll take the win yeah yeah it was i
mean any any good news i'm sure is uh
nice to hold on to you um speaking of
good news you posted something on
facebook uh there's some statistic that
uh healthcare workers are
of any
professional demographic they're getting
sick less with kovid um
are you stalking me now what's going on
no i happen to i actually don't have
facebook this is christian who's now
being silent christian told me about
this oh awkward geez he follows you up
yeah no actually uh yeah that makes
sense um no that's a great actually i
wanted to bring that up thanks for
bringing it up because um
i think it raises a few interesting
points there was recently a report that
came out that showed
in new york in particular that the most
of the people coming in now who are
newly infected are coming from community
exposure
and uh when you think about it think
about it like our job every day i go
into a shift i absolutely 100 percent
and i'm exposed to someone who i know
has it and is symptomatic and coughing
and whatever
um and so the fact that
me and my population of healthcare
workers are getting sick less than the
general public should tell you something
uh we're doing something right in the
hospital in terms of protecting
ourselves
can you then extrapolate that can you do
you think uh
there's something that everyone could
learn from that in in other
professional effects
yes okay
um
one of my favorite uh you know medical
spokes people and uh
he wrote an article that just came out
also i think in the new yorker about
what will it take to sort of reopen
safely and he he sort of talks about
four things which are you know of course
things we do in the hospital as well
which are hygiene you know so i think
surprising as it sounds a lot of people
have learned about how to properly wash
our hands and that sort of sort of thing
that's great um the second would be
screening and so
we're not totally there yet as a country
but we've gotten way better in terms of
availability of testing now and
screening and some proactive screening
in particular areas like nursing homes
um social distancing is something that
everyone's uh learned about i think
that's going to i think from you know
what i'm noticing around new york
you know just going outside you can you
can see the difference people are taking
more risks in that way
and and if that's why the fourth thing
of masks has to continue so
i think
you know i was thinking about this
justin and i think that
um
we have to think about what are
reasonable risks in our life because
covet is just one of many many risks in
our in our lives and um now that we're
past that phase of really trying to all
protect um you know from a public health
standpoint to hospitals from being
overwhelmed in a surge uh or i'd like to
think we're past it i guess it could
come back but for now um you know
what does it mean to to sort of go back
to our lives um i i don't like this sort
of you know dialogue that's happening of
like there are people with mass people
without masks and dividing into camps i
think i think you know
it's we need to figure out ways to
reasonably return to our lives and stay
safe and follow those four principles
that uh dr gwande was talking about and
also
that is keeping us safe in the hospital
so it is possible you have to basically
you know
um just be act like the doctors and
nurses yeah be diligent and and uh i
wonder what that'll mean specifically
for any kind of like restaurant
situation or group setting um i
selfishly i'm thinking about i i so miss
the theater and i miss going the theater
i miss i miss performing um
i wonder what that kind of thing will
look like um
but that's
there are lots of creative ideas about
it um
you know it will never go i think it'll
never go back to how it was i don't know
that we want to go back to how it was we
want to be better uh we had to be
creative about it and that's why i i
just urge in that conversation i think i
think it's natural right now that people
been cooped up for so long that's why
the vaccine stuff is like okay great but
it's it's not soon enough because right
now human nature is kicking in
and uh our less intelligent part of
human nature tells us like well you know
screw this and this mask is making me
tired i'm gonna take it off
um but i think about like well what's
changed and what hasn't changed from day
one you know what hasn't changed is we
still don't have a vaccine so until we
do it you know the the risk is still out
there has that has not changed at all
um
you know and so i think that that the
policy right now of sort of like you
wearing a mask and your friend wearing a
mask and you guys staying good six feet
apart
that should just be the norm for a while
but but i don't think i think i think we
can consider reasonable risk in other
words like we don't have to stay
socially isolated in our houses by
ourself and i say that because i don't
think people can anymore
and but it shouldn't be all or nothing
like okay now that i'm not going to stay
home i'm going to go throw a tiger
right i'll tell you something so so
first of all i want to um my nephew was
just born this this week on the 18th so
from jordan
yeah but you know of course so i feel
like everyone else like you know i want
to i would love to see him now he's in
la so i won't be doing that any time
soon but uh but our grand but um you
know my my father-in-law uh came by the
other day stayed outside didn't come
inside brought his own food and drink he
had a mask we had a mask we stayed you
know
eight to ten years apart but you know we
were able to sort of see each other and
that was nice that's nice because i our
mother i mean you know you know her
mother she's just climbing the walls
she's like freaking out about not being
able to see her grandkids and we really
miss our our nephews as well um
but uh that's good to hear maybe we'll
try to figure something out along those
lines well i would i would co i i could
talk to uh damien i'll clear your mom to
i don't know i don't know about you and
christian i'll have to think about okay
yeah no i know we're uh terry and
something probably i'm just kidding no
but i think i think that's what we need
to talk about because i think again like
people are pitting it's the usual stuff
people are dividing into camps the media
is pitting people against each other as
if there's people who are afraid
huddling in a corner and you know
wearing mask while there's the rest of
the you know this other group that's
brave and going out and protesting you
know it's all just a fake narrative
right i know and i get on both sides i
mean you know sometimes you see and we
live in a meme culture too in social
media you see you see like the signs
where i want a haircut and
it's not it's not so much about that
i underst people are suffering people
need to go back to work they want to go
back to work it's they're living and i
think it's also exposed we've talked
about this how it's so such a huge part
of the population is living paycheck to
paycheck that um you know it's easy for
people like well like me privileged
people who have the luxury of being able
to stay inside and not go to work and or
who work from their homes it's easy to
say
oh just you know write it out and i i
but i have to be
sympathetic to the people who don't have
that luxury who need to go back to work
and we need to cut hair you know but but
this is also why right
like people like the hospital's been
open right and not just doctors and
nurses who get a lot of the attention
but but food service workers and social
workers and everyone across the spectrum
of course our environmental services
people who if they were not keeping you
know all the surfaces clean
you know on i don't think god even knows
quadruple the schedule they used to do
in terms of cleaning surfaces then i
would be getting sick and so it you know
my you know the new york uh healthcare
um
you know there's hundreds of thousands
of people that work there now and and
again
we are getting less sick than people who
have been sheltered in their apartment
and then just decided to go out for a
walk talk to somebody yeah pull down the
mask for a second because they feel
weird that's who yeah you know so we
have to be vigilant like we are in the
hospital well yeah that is such such
good advice dave and um yeah it's funny
i i just came from new york i i was
there for just a couple hours and i
noticed so many people even people with
masks were who were jogging riding bikes
whatever
were wearing them below they're almost
like they were like chin straps like
they weren't actually wearing them um
so this is yeah this is what i'm saying
if i go into a room and i'm like ah it's
a little bit annoying let me pull down
my mask that's what i'm getting yeah
and so i have no problem with people
being out go bike go run just wear your
mask like a doctor and a nurse and and
the environmental service person like
who does their job and keeps that mask
on it's hard it is hard but if you can't
do that then you're taking a risk well
and not a reasonable that's great dave
thank you for that and um really quick i
just want to mention again uh your
friends
uh the food drive that they're doing
it's
gratafoodnyc.org is that right
yes yes yes gratifiednyc.org and that is
going to uh well because the the food
banks in new york are uh running low so
they're they're you know uh working in
conjunction with the food banks and
helping to supply them and uh and such a
cool thing if there's any anything else
you wanted to mention so needed right
now well um christian might have seen
this because i posted it on facebook but
but there's been another blood shortage
alert in new york city yeah you know
wherever you are in the country it's
never a bad time to give blood there's
always uh there's always a need for that
yeah
and and and more importantly just sort
of like you might think of uh
putting money away for savings every
month you know a little bit like blood
blood works the same way because it
expires you know a lot of times during
disasters we see people rush to give
blood and then it all goes back yeah um
you know being a deficit again consider
being a regular blood donor it's
something that will always uh contribute
to saving lives that's a really good
idea
i should do that that's an easy thing to
do um good thinking dave thanks uh
and they're clean i mean of all the
places oh yeah
you know they're gonna be a very clean
place today okay good thank you for that
um and thanks always dave so really nice
hearing your voice
oh i almost forgot i have uh get in in
the other earbud is my daughter oh yeah
how's the uh is she she's just in there
listening i was gonna phone a friend
about the green day thing but i don't
know if she knows that
how old is she
say sayla can you i don't know if you
could hear her
hey sayla
you hear her hey
hey shayla do you know that song when i
come around
no oh never mind do you know the song um
what's the other one
saylor what bands do you like what what
music do you like
i don't know pop music oh okay oh like j
um jojo dojo cat
do you know that one taylor swift taylor
swift
do you like
yeah
what's your favorite we like what's your
favorite t-swizz song
i don't know all right did you know that
uh some kids call taylor swift t swizz
yeah yeah i didn't know yeah really yeah
yeah well you should tell you should
tell your dad these things
she teaches me all the all the cool new
links yeah
oh hey it was good talking to you thanks
for being on the show
are you having fun are you having fun at
home with dad
yeah
she can give you lots of dirt
oh boy okay that might be a whole she
should be our next guest okay
how's the uh
yeah i mean actually the it is it is
interesting like the experience of
kids right now in quarantine i know say
i don't want to speak for you but i feel
like she was really upset about
um missing school she loves uh celery
and i also heard yeah i say i heard
you're missing the play
that's justin
well you set me up dave you brought it
up uh sorry sayla that stinks
that stinks what what play not to dwell
on it but what play were you gonna do
um oh
man
well
next uh next year i bet you'll do an
even better play
yeah wow let's get something to look
forward to
yeah okay but say you know yeah we might
do actually we found like an online
good idea you can try it out i don't
know oh that'll be fun that'll be fun
and also you know your daddy he's
probably a good actor you guys can just
read different plays at home you can do
different readings
um
oh mommy's perfect so you got three
performers right there
you do peter pan you can do all the hits
i gotta let you know she's like
multitasking
oh thanks okay
well please tell sayla that i was
focused on our conversation i'm doing um
where are you
thanks thanks thanks dave thanks guys
yeah
well
you're very welcome we'll check in with
you next week great checking in always
absolutely love the christian and and
the rest of the things
shout out to the show oh likewise uh
thanks and if you want to say hi to
jerry he's he may be listening
oh well tell him i said i want to do a
saxophone that with him okay okay tell
him to uh you know alto sax i played
along oh
all right tell him to keep okay i will
jerry you hear that uh okay thanks buddy
talk to you soon
all right take care bye
look play saxophone too oh what can you
do yeah
uh that's funny that sailor was not
focused on because it sounded like she
wasn't focused
it sounded like she was i pictured her i
know this is not what she was doing but
like holding a game boy playing uh
tetris or something is that the one that
does something really impressive i think
they all do something really good no but
didn't he mention last week that she was
like oh she she was supposed to do that
play no but more than the play was like
she does something like we were like oh
she can speak 17 languages yeah uh
anyway oh thanks to dave that was um
the good some good some good news some
good news but that was i can't believe
how
confidently he said that things will
never go back
to the way they were yeah that was a
little disgusting a little scary yeah
but you know i think in some ways that's
a good thing like we've talked about the
shaking hands thing i almost burped yeah
did you can you yeah now i want to take
what i tell you like we've talked about
i was just wondering
i know we're both shout out to uh
lacroix coconut like they need it no but
coconut flavor okay then i'm gonna shout
out waterloo
uh it says they have a legendary taste
water loose delicious myself that's so
good god celestia are we just talking
about i don't know too much weed
ah you idiot
justin just spilled sausage
microphone oh uh oh oh and the
phone clean it off the microphone first
oh okay oh on the microphone no no the
bot just the best
that was one of the nerdiest things
i've ever i've ever did i've ever done
and i was about to wow like i'm cleaning
it all with my
funnier dye
sweatshirt no that sucks oh well it'll
dry
it provided great content
the listeners are gonna love that
i wonder if that'll be funny if you
can't see it
i bet it will be it was really fun
because it looks like it it looked like
it turned over in slow motion
and i well it was pouring for so long
until you until i pointed it out to you
well uh we don't remember what we were
talking um seltzer water
oh lacroix
now it was before that oh well coconut
oh hey you know speaking of shout outs
uh impressive daughter oh things not
going back to where they were
yeah that is i remember uh shaking hands
oh yeah you know what sucks okay yeah i
know that's i'm saying that's a good
thing if we don't respond to that yeah
um
especially for uh although i was
supposed to do one of those conventions
you know where you that's literally all
you do is shake hands i don't know what
they're going to do for that thing
uh
and
oh god this is so uh um
anyway yeah you know what i know you
know this already and i'm so
disappointed in myself about it but we
interviewed i interviewed how we met now
recently and um
i laughed during that i was so bad at
keeping secrets i know but
it's not a was a crazy secret no but i
know it's it's it's exciting people in
their feed to see who the new guest is
and it's a total surprise well
over the course of the last two episodes
you like have slipped into the
conversation like the next ten guests
okay all right well i i say it only
because you know he's he's known for
being a germaphobe and and now this
stuff we were talking amongst other
things of course that's not the only
thing he's known for famous germaphobe
no but we talked about that and uh he is
though he's probably the most famous
german folk yeah yeah and uh he talks it
was really
so fascinating talking about his ocd and
where it came from i'm excited for
people to listen to it sorry i ruined
the surprise but uh the one thing that
you had written was a great question
that i forgot to ask him was how does he
think people should greet each other in
the future in the in the in the post
covid world
and i didn't ask him i'm so curious
if i had to guess i would say he would
say
uh just by bumping genitals was uh
stranger
oh yeah that's true
genital bump softly of course you don't
want to hurt anyone no yeah uh yeah
that's a good it's a good theory that
was fun talking to them it's fun talking
to kids life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge-watching
low-budget made for tv holiday movies
the all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
justin and i did another episode of
celebrity watch party yeah and one of
the things we watched was this
um
it was this thing that lebron james was
hosting this sort of like digital
um
graduation uh-huh ceremony where oh
oh this was funny and we were talking
about our that's the ben platt thing
yeah so bet so they show that's not
that's not what i was gonna bring out
but first let me say they were talking
about
you know everyone being so sad that
they're missing their graduations and
they prompted us to talk about uh
our own graduations and our best
memories of you know that time yeah and
i i didn't yield much like so for me
the experience of going to prom and
graduation these things that are so
important hallmarks in people's lives
they were never that important to me so
i know that people it sucks for seniors
now who don't get to do all that
graduation stuff but
i'm trying to put myself in their shoes
and it doesn't bum me out that much
thinking about it because i was never
that into that stuff but there are some
kids who
who were so i mean obviously so in to
that kind of stuff and like the thing i
can commiserate with salah about is not
being if i if if i had been
rehearsing for a play but that's what
was important to me was doing if i could
didn't
yeah so part of this like you said part
of this uh show that lebron james is
hosting that we were commenting on on
national television none of which
they're gonna use no was uh there was a
segment where ben platt and his two
brothers i didn't even know he had two
brothers
sang
um
kind of a
medley
of different songs as we go i mean one
of them was that yeah and
man at one point i started i was so
moved
i looked over at christian and he had
his his jaw his mouth was like a gape
and he i
he was wearing glasses so i thought
maybe i just saw a reflection in his eye
and i looked closer and he they were
misty they were you were tearing he was
tearing up and they're filming us this
is like for a show on
network tv well i was i was tearing up
not only because it was such a beautiful
performance i'm not shaming you for that
but it was they were singing my favorite
song
as part of this medley also you love
i love ben platt too but it was like in
my life they were singing and i oh yeah
that is your favorite i was getting
emotional and then
as i was getting emotional eye it dawned
on me because when you're doing the show
you kind of get into this you know what
yeah the mode of watching tv and just
being on your couch and talking it's
easy to forget the camera exactly it's
easy to forget that you're actually
being filmed and you're on tv so i was
in one of those moments where i started
to get emotional and i then i remembered
that oh
i'm on national tv
and if they use this because they can
use whatever they want really right
we'll find out tomorrow night they
probably won't or tonight depending on
but uh but if they
they might use that they might me
getting emotional
on national tv
you're saying it's a nice thing i i
don't think it's anything to be ashamed
of
i think it's i think it's not i think
it's like shows here
shows you're sensitive we'll see i mean
or it might be fun i mean it'll be funny
to me
because i know that it's like someone
i'm not saying it's embarrassing in
general for a man to get emotional i
know i know what am i getting emotional
at
just a really nice performance by ben
platt it's kind of an odd thing in your
defense it was more than a nice
performance it was like beautiful it was
like i
transplundent yeah
transplant
i in i had a moment like that i mean it
wasn't being filmed for a network show
but a couple of nights earlier i was uh
i almost said i was stoned but who cares
um a couple nights earlier i i found the
i was did i did we talked about this the
simon and garfunkel concert in central
park yes holy yeah i came i was
similar i rounded the corner and you
were like
all glassy-eyed
i was mouth-gay
you know stoned or not yeah watching the
concert in central park by simon
garfunkel
by yourself with friends whoever
it is
such an experience
please don't come she will ah that was
good your face looked really nice when
you sing this you know what's funny
though it's crazy
[Music]
it's crazy
it's crazy how different
simon and garfunkel were those people
and you can t you can see it in the in
that performance i mean i know you know
that i'm just you know you could
uh
place paul simon in a in a biopic that
if you learn to sing better
much better this is an interesting thing
about life
i there was a kid named brian french not
to out him i really liked him actually
he was like
the tom brady of our sixth grade class
he was
in sixth grade this guy was chiseled you
know he had like
you know him right i don't know if
that's appropriate for a 41 year old man
that's true maybe that's
but i knew him i'm saying it you were
also i was in sixth grade yeah he's now
a 41 year old man so i'm talking about
another 40. i understand
but at the time it's so borderline it is
i think so but i have a memory of six
i've been i'm not saying i saw him
yesterday as a sixth grader
i'm saying mike and you were not
chiseled as a sixth person oh my god i
was
so far from that you were just like a p
you were like uh you were like a pile of
dough yeah
that was a little underformed uh there
was a review once and i'll never forget
it michelle orange movie line magazine
she said it was for the movie going the
distance she caught she just made fun of
my looks and she said that i was um i
had
oh now i've forgotten it she i had
unformed features wow yeah it was really
uh i would say if anything your features
are over formed oh thanks well no it's
bad i mean you have nice big features
but my point wait wait but the point
about brian was that he used to call me
and i don't think he necessarily meant
it as an insult but i took it that way
he used to call me paul simon he also
called me curious george yeah oh that's
what i thought you called me curious
george and paul simon and both were
insulting to me yeah but both
are now somewhat accurate yes you looked
a little bit like curious george yes and
paul simon and now you watch this the
concert in central park that paul
there's no greater compliment than being
compared to paul simon who is
so
like the epitome of cool in this concert
and in
fascinatingly in other i mean aside from
the music when you watch this concert in
central park sex appeal
yeah that's all right but i'm saying i
don't think that's how brian mentioned
it
aside from he he thought i had sex
appeared aside from the music which is
an incredible to watch
it's there's such a fascinating dynamic
at play between paul simon and art
garfunkel
in that paul simon is the coolest the
smoothest yeah the most charming person
whereas
our art garfunkel who has the voice of
an angel obviously yeah is
like kind of the opposite
he's
he comes out he soaks up the audience
soaks it up he's kind of awkward when he
gestures to the audience he plays he's
he
he is uh they're opposites they're
opposites yeah that way it's amazing
and it's interesting to see how they
relate to each other garfunkel is you
could see it's he's all about himself
and the adulation he's getting whereas
paul simon is like clearly
miffed and annoyed by garfunkel's
behavior once you once you discover that
and become aware of it it's hard to see
it it is yeah and so then the rest of
the concert
it becomes so apparent becomes like
amplified every song they sing like it
becomes increasingly more amplified and
i like our old-fashioned quarantine
recommendations
i know oh my god you're taking this
concert a tape for this concert 75
i know i think it was earlier it was oh
uh i see i thought it was early 80s
i thought it was 80 i think it's 81. i
think oh you're right you're right
you're right yeah and uh what else have
we been recommending like old michael
jordan footage
kristen marx brothers movies
oh my god dookie by green day
that's right
it's pretty weird how you're just like
playing with your mustache right now uh
well when you have a mustache you'll see
that it's hard not to pull on it it's
you also did a gross thing the other day
christian goes uh you know what a cool
thing about having a mustache and i
looked at him and
he just like licked he you like licked
it you like
i didn't lick it you like sometimes
there's like a little drop like a sip of
something the bottom there's a little
droplet gets stuck and you just
and it's gross also an embarrassing
mustache thing just happened to me i
took a sip out of my lacroix
can i keep plugging lacroix it's so good
i know but they're fine
i'm not doing it to get them more
business i'm doing this stuff oh yeah
hey oh no i am doing i like like you
don't both have to want to get free
products from lacroix so i took a sip of
my lacroix coconut flavor wow and uh a a
strand of my mustache hair hooked onto
the little pop tab
and as i pulled off and made a dium
sound
oh yeah it hurts so much
so that is uh that's a reason not to
have a mustache yeah but the ladies oh
they're
crazy they're going crazy this whole
conversation they're going crazy yeah uh
oh speaking of plugging products that um
we we really genuinely love and are not
getting paid for uh honey mamas oof oh
boy honey mamas um
just first of all the nicest people
they're out of portland oregon but uh
more importantly a lot of good things
come out of portland oregon yeah yeah i
miss portland so honey mama's honey
mama's is a is um it's a treat it's a
brick it's a bar of it's made with
coconut meat uh cocoa and all natural
ingredients it's all non-soy non-gmo not
gluten i believe
it's just it's it's like paleo specific
uh
it's not a lot of sugar too you taste
this thing and it's made with i think
it's right it's the yeah honey it's the
right amount of sweetness it is and
there's so many different flavors and
unique flavors our favorite was there
was one called tahini tangerine you got
a it's just delicious it is just google
it google it order it they deliver
excuse me uh and i gave some too much to
our parents and they just went nuts for
it uh so thanks to paul downes and cate
berlant for recommending honey mamas and
thanks to honey mamas for sending us
some we love it and we wouldn't mind
more right right and that's not why
we're doing this we just love it um hey
let's read a
uh would you rather letter let's do it
okay ready yeah do you want me to read
her do you want to go ahead okay
okay this from roxy
c
roxy c yes whoa cool name hello hello
justin christian i'm roxy carmichael
close yeah i'm a huge fan of the show
but i'm a bit behind on episodes this
week i've been binge listening to the
choir episodes because they truly are
such a source of joy for me during these
uncertain times
i usually listen during my daily walk
slash runs and i can't tell you how many
times i laugh out loud when listening
especially when you check in with jerry
we haven't been able to get in touch
with jerry i was super excited when you
started sharing would you rather's about
two years ago my husband jack and i and
our friends kathy and jay went to new
york city to visit our friend olivia
jack and roxy that's a cool couple name
picture it new york city early august
waiting for the subway dripping sweat i
can i can really yeah put myself in that
oh man position you know what's weird i
miss that me too
you don't bother me sweating on the
subway platform
this is where our would you rather
journey began although credit should go
to olivia because she started it
we came up with a long list of would you
rather's and decided my husband jack
should illustrate them we created an
instagram account would you uh would you
rather drawings
would your rather drawings
and my hope is to one day turn these
into a book we can all have below are a
few of my favorite would you rather
questions i think you'll enjoy wait a
minute uh should we look at the
instagram i want to look at it let's
look at it after this oh okay
uh again oh she gets she listed since
you know this is a show remember she
listed some we're on a show what yeah
now
again i'm a huge fan of the podcast
especially the choir episodes i hope
once the quar is over it's hard to say
that the choir yeah you continue with
that hasn't slipped into my binoculars i
hope i hope once the quara is over you
continue with post-car check-in episodes
because they bring needed joy and
laughter to people so stay safe all the
best roxy thank you okay she has ten
would you rathers let's plow through
these
number one
gross
would you rather have a permanent sore
on your eyelid or your butthole oh my
god
oh my god that's good my gut instinct is
is i'd rather have it on my butthole
oh and only only because the visibility
the visibility yeah uh but the the
comfort oh man
sore on an eyeball or eyelid eyelid see
i think the butthole is more sensitive i
think so too
but the eyelid is
not only are will people see you have a
sore on your eyelid presumably you'll be
like um
elliott and something about me yeah
not only people see you have the sore
which might be difficult to deal with
but yeah it might make it difficult to
see
it would help to know what type of sore
i mean like
here's the thing with the butthole is
that
not to get too graphic but
you're going to disturb it
more than you would and i live
sore right i mean uh it's easier to
disturb maybe but i don't know hopefully
well not necessarily because with an
idea you're constantly opening and
closing you'd have to get a bidet
uh yeah yeah okay well okay i would say
that's not dwelling i would say
buttonholes okay number two you don't
both have to want to above 12
number two number two would you rather
have four balls
oh
you just spit out yourself
would you rather oh my god roxy
uh that was it i haven't had
i haven't had a genuine spit taking a
long time all right would you rather
have four balls just spit out my
waterloo or seltzer water or a permanent
mini boner
uh
what are they called a uh semi semi
yeah a meat
no meat are just
aren't they just penises that haven't
been uh don't get as big when they
become boners there's always big and
yeah they're soft or hard
yeah yeah that's a meat cup my friend
jeremy told us that the difference
between a meat cocking and bloodcock
anyway um
four balls or a permanent mini boner um
i guess it depends how many how many
yeah what percentage would it be
uh what do you think i would say
i would say
let's say it's 50
oh well then that'd be tough to walk
around with all the time i know
i would say four balls because not to be
too graphic but
when i was 20 years old i
had i would pick the four balls over the
mini bone
balls the same size as regular yeah your
balls now
yeah just two more of those yeah but
because no i'm saying like what if you
chose to have smaller balls you can't oh
yeah
shows to have smaller balls
like those cadbury eggs that sweet those
cabbage cadbury minis well when i was 20
i had a a hernia and
it
it looked like i i got it surgically
but it looked like i had a third ball
for a while so i kind of got used to the
luke the third ball league oh that third
ball luke so we'll have three balls i
can imagine having four balls could you
get you know how i mean if you have one
ball removed as i don't want to say but
uh there are people that we a lot of
people yeah a lot of people i was to say
future yeah um but uh if you get that
removed you can have a prosthetic of
course
replace that one i wonder if some people
i wonder if you can
get a cosmetic third ball put in maybe
i'm sure people have done that
i would do
just to show off just to be like
different and as long as they fit in in
the situation i have now i would take
the four balls um yeah but think about
like mini boner all the time
yeah but fifty percent there there goes
uh athletic shorts
i don't wear a lot of athletic shoes no
you don't and i wear a lot of jeans and
i feel like a g it would i think it
would contain it you wear pretty tight
jeans i don't know if you can contain it
well thanks well it depends how many you
are yeah all right yeah there's four
balls but balls are cumbersome i i think
i might take the
i don't know all right no good one
though number three would you rather
never be able to brush your teeth or
wipe your butt oh god these are good oh
easy for me uh wait wait oh never well
you get the bidet exactly yeah you it
would be annoying or splashing you'd
have to shower every time you yeah did
stuff you know it would help me brush
your teeth you would get it would be so
bad you would also get infections no one
would ever want to hang out with you you
would your teeth would rot out yeah
butthole for sure yeah easy
um number four would you rather store on
it would you rather always
cross
i already got the bidet because the butt
sword all right number four would you
rather always have mosquito bites all
over your body or always be sunburned oh
man
um bites i think really i would say
sunburn you know why because
really yeah because
healing and and
oh see i'm not imagining the peeling
part i'm gonna always be that's what i
was gonna say as long as the sun burned
didn't as part of this is not like
leading to swelling cancer keto bites
could lead to west nile that's true but
let's say there's none of that risk it
was just it was just um
the feel and the look of it you have to
deal with
i would much rather have sunburn i think
that's tough because sunburn is
then you you just look like that's what
your skin looks like that's the shade of
your skin you look like whereas mosquito
bites yeah you look like you have little
sores all over your body you look like
uh like a german tourist or something
you know it's right like like a
ruddy-faced pleasure house yeah in key
west you look like a european tourist
who who went to florida and like did it
and wasn't prepared for the power of the
sun exactly whereas mosquito bites not
only would it look more
noticeable true imagine always itching
well the sunburn is uncomfortable
obviously but it's not
as you make a goal you make a really
good case yeah here's why i was tempted
first to say mosquito bites and this is
a very weird reason i know but um since
i had that the poison ivy all over me
which is almost gone away ladies
um i
there there's something so i'm actually
gonna miss this about having poison ivy
there's something so satisfying about
standing in a warm shower and just like
the satisfaction of the relief of that
itch of how it would relieve the itch
temporarily
and it would also
clean your butt and oh yeah balls and
your mini bone yeah my sword you don't
accomplish so much four balls
uh okay number five we got
six more boys what time is it we gotta
plow out yeah okay number five would you
rather have really long eyebrows long
enough to braid past your chin eyebrows
or no eyebrows
no eyebrows
really
you just your eyebrows just went off i'm
just picturing you not having that you
have such thick eyebrows
yeah it's a it's a big part of how i
express that
it'd be weird it's not too weird you'd
look like i never get work again i could
put fake eyebrows on no you can't not
not this hypothetical
can i braid the eyebrows into like
eyebrow dreadlocks yeah
i guess i'd maybe have to sort something
out with that they go down to your what
uh chin are you picture are you trying
i'm trying to picture you that eyebrows
it's almost impossible to do it would be
it'd be tough
but eyebrows that go down like this
imagine me with eyebrows that go down to
my chin crazy to imagine they're like
curtains you know what you can do you
can just put them behind your ears oh
yeah
yeah that's funny i
might do that put them behind your ears
yeah then you just wear glasses a lot
and try to you could tape them along
that's a good rim of your glasses i'll
do that okay i'm picking the eyebrows
all right number six number six would
you rather have hands for feet or feet
for hands oh i've thought about this i
would rather have uh
feet uh
hands for hands for feet yeah hands for
feet put him in a shoe
yeah you learned to walk on your hands
and you yeah
uh okay
number seven would you rather only be
able to shower once a week
or have unlimited baths you could never
just shower you would always have to
take a bath to get clean but you could
take three baths a day if you wanted to
uh
i would take the baths well see because
this one is unlimited baths or shower
once it's shower once a week or only be
able to take back baths i think
especially because if there's a person
in your life that
has to smell you yeah of course that'd
be real but if i was alone and i knew
for a fact i would never
have
close human contact again for the rest
of my life go ahead i would pick i think
the once a week shower
then you get a really good clean once a
week yeah but then you're writing
manifestos in a little shack yeah you
have bigger problems then but yeah but i
would but as long as life was the way it
is now then i would pick the baths yeah
i like a good bath me too but i i don't
have a bathtub now but i'll figure that
out okay number eight would you rather
clean your butthole while you're at it
would you rather burp farts
or
think about how often you sweat and you
sweat i sweat a lot um
people are gonna think i'm disgusting
burp farts well
farts so you have to just and you roll
the dice on yeah
it's bad
no but then you're very benign you have
to taste it then that's what that means
because even if you burp when you burp
you expel some burps some of my burps
are on on par with a fart
sorry
sorry you know i mean if you eat
something he says proudly something you
know eat like uh
like pepperoni or something something
disgusting ah that doesn't smell like
producing
it doesn't smell like a fart but it
smells more offensive than some of my
some some farts it's hard to say some
farts can be very benign
yeah but everyone likes their own brand
right i know i'm not even saying that
i'm saying like a fart that doesn't
really smell but here's the point you
would have versus a burp that you would
have a fart taste in your mouth when you
burped that's the gross part to me
that's pretty gross because if if if not
for that then i would pick the um i
would pick that option because then you
could always just cover your mouth and
make sure you're away from people when
you're burping and well especially now
with you know a mask wearing culture
you'd be smelling farts all the time
because yeah uh yeah i've noticed that
sometimes
i'm sure everyone else too we're wearing
masks all the time and we're much more
aware of what that smells like our
breath smells like sometimes i don't
find it like it's bad but it's not what
i thought
i think i don't mind it but i'm like oh
god i i'm always so paranoid that my
breath smells sweating urine isn't so
bad to me the thought of that well again
it depends on how bad asparagus urine
that's different that's so specific so
that you would never eat asparagus
when you're well hydrated
your pee
i think has almost no smell that's true
that's true that's true and when you
just have to make sure that you're very
well hydrated i would encourage you to
do that which is good in general okay
uh number nine
last two number nine would you rather
have a permanent backage or
a permanent tickle in your throat oh man
these are good
uh
i think i'd rather have the permanent
tickle in the throat
the package i think would drive me crazy
faster
you don't i think i could get used to
the uh throat you would have to adjust
the way you talked and you you'd yeah
but you would be scratching and all that
i don't think i'd ever get used to
having an itch in my back that i
couldn't scratch i think that you would
i bet you i would i think i'd be
tormented by that
i bet you'd get used to anything but i
would take the throat itch too it would
be easier to status last but not least
number 10 would you rather floss with
floss someone else already used oh god
or
wear someone else's dirty underwear can
you pick the person that's what i was
going to say it totally depends on the
yeah i mean if it was like a lever let's
say if it let's say i'm gonna hear
would you rather use my floss or my
underwear that's tough would you rather
use my floss or my or my thong underwear
okay okay
what thong underwear
wait can i wipe off the the floss and
what's up can i wipe off the thong
yeah yeah with your hand but not with it
all right
then i would pick the floss
i would rather wear your underwear
really yeah
my thong underwear uh
it's different i mean my snacks
underwear
it's plugged with a plug yeah uh
if you were to wear thong underwear i
would here's the art so rather wear your
thong underwear something about it turns
my stomach imagining using your used
floss there's something awful about
cause it's going in your mouth too and
just like little bits of food well you
could wipe it off you'd get that food
off just with your fingers yeah yeah i
couldn't do it i'd rather wear your
underwear okay
well fortunately we don't have to do
this that you know what i also like
about these would you rather it it
reminds you how nice things are the way
they are that i don't have to i don't
have to wear your thong thank god yeah
me too thank god for me well thanks
again roxy those oh yeah thank god for
roxy
jack little story about roxy and jeff
and if you guys have good would you
rathers
we would love to hear them we would love
for you to email them to us at
lifeisshortwondery.com
yeah or if you want to write us a letter
that doesn't have a would you rather in
it and just a letter about what you're
doing during quarantine if you want to
recommend a local business or if you
have a local business that would be like
honey mamas like honey mamas they have
an instagram site too at honeymommas.com
uh we love hearing from you guys life is
short onedrive.com and thank you to dr
dave as always yes and thanks to jerry
for listening yes and you know but don't
be intimidated by roxy's would you
rather's roxy and jax because those are
those are next level we
you know just send them send us if you
ha if you have them or if your kids have
them oh those are always good they're
ideal
uh okay well thank you to everyone and
to billy joe armstrong for inspiring
justin
at the beginning of this episode and
yeah you had the time to listen to me
wine head back that could be a theme
song for this do you have the time to
listen to me whine
about nothing and everything and thank
you all of you listening for listening
to us wine yeah for listening to us um
have fun talking to each other
in quarantine and we hope you have a
great weekend and we'll see on tuesday
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by you christian law
it's also produced by megan monaco
senior producers michelle
audio engineer is sergio enriquez the
executive boosters are marshall louis
and hernan lopez for wandery
bye
oh
[Music]
you